[Música]
bom primeiro que eu prefiro ficar dando
cambalhotas subindo matava os 10
centímetros do que tá aqui topar o
desafio onde está passando um pouquinho
da minha experiência das minhas
realizações como atleta pra vocês minhas
realizações começam até muito novinha
não parece mas eu comecei com quatro
anos e meio hoje a ponto de completar 35
anos
são 30 anos de carreira e de realizações
que a gente tem seus altos seus baixos
suas falhas suas vitórias e todas
servirão como realizações para que
dentro dentro da minha carreira eu
pudesse ser uma pessoa realizada meus
sonhos concretizados e hoje podendo
passar adiante numa outra fase da minha
vida que também é um desafio também é
uma nova realização que é o início da
transição de carreira que é você
entender que o sport ele é lindo e
maravilhoso mas ele chegou o seu momento
de 100 cerrado e você iniciar outra fase
que são outros desafios novas metas
novos empenhos e novas realizações
eu comecei isso é no sesi de santo andré
com uns quatro anos e meio porque eu no
início eu via a primeira nota 10 da
história da ginástica
nádia como a net passando alguns
trechinhos né porque naquela época não
passava mais é não passava ginástica de
uma forma como passa hoje que se passam
competições inteiros para que o público
pudesse possa acompanhar ea nossa
representante da época luisa parente eu
comecei a pegar o colchão da cama da
minha mãe levava até o quintal da minha
casa
a minha mãe é procurar o colchão onde
estava o chão do quintal de casa e eu
brincando de correr e da famosa sterling
em cima do colchão
aí voltava correndo no pique até o final
do portão corria de novo ficava fazendo
estrelinha
por coincidência um professor do sesi
que hoje não se encontra mais com a
gente me convidou para fazer um teste na
escolinha do sesi para ver se eu
conseguiria ter aptidão para passar à
equipe em conseguir passar no teste e
três anos depois a minha treinadora que
até hoje trabalha no sesi minha primeira
treinadora virou pra mim e falou que eu
não poderia mais ficar no sesi porque eu
tinha uma capacidade que ela não tinha
ali uma estrutura para que eu pudesse
realizar mais do que aquilo que eu
esperava que estava realizando ali
naquele momento que era ser destaque do
futuro no nas competições dos regionais
dos abertos e foi aí que começa a minha
grande realização que foi uma menina de
8 anos decide a vida da família inteira
que era a família toda
vindo mudando para o rio através de um
sonho de menina que poderia ter se
realizado ou poderia não ter se
realizado da forma com que foi com keiko
que foi realizado e nisso ainda veio meu
irmão conjunto que depois anos depois
ele também foi um grande medalhista é um
grande medalhista então foram
realizações da família não só minha
porque a minha família sempre esteve do
meu lado a minha família topou uma
mudança de vida uma mudança de cidade
uma mudança de ambiente de ter que
refazer a vida de conquistar novos
amigos se ambientar em outra cidade que
eles não estavam acostumados e pra ver
junto com os filhos a realização de um
sonho
foram cinco jogos olímpicos
a dani mas você não ganha uma medalha
olímpica
você é realizada
sou muito tenho muito orgulho da
carreira que eu construir
tenho muito orgulho de ter tido a
oportunidade através de uma mão
estendida de voltar com a primeira
medalha da história dos mundiais de
ginástica artística que foi a medalha de
prata em 2001 no solo ea partir desse
momento vê a ginástica através da minha
realização viagem nazca trazendo outras
realizações que aí veio daiane diego e
jade vieram vários a net
as duas equipes tanto masculina quanto a
feminina estando como equipe e já em
edições dos jogos olímpicos
isso através de uma realização de um
sonho de uma menina que a família
acreditou que a família postou e que
nesse meio tempo eu trouxe meu irmão
comigo e que são realizações que a dani
mas a sua maior realização é sua medalha
do mundial não é a maior realização é
aquilo que as minhas determinações os
meus sonhos dos meus focos as minhas
competições me transformaram como pessoa
pierre a determinação de não ter medo é
terá o foco de saber que a gente pode se
errar a gente pode sem falhar porque os
erros também fazem parte do aprendizado
porque se tudo der certo a gente sempre
acertasse se sempre as mesmas pessoas
ganhassem as medalhas não precisava ter
competição era só você mandar a medalha
para casa da pessoa que você saber que
ela chegava na competição
ela ia ganhar as competições servem para
o aprendizado e os meus maiores
aprendizados foram nas minhas falhas
porque é onde você pára pra pensar aonde
você errou para aquela realização que
você tinha colocado como meta não tem
acontecido naquele momento a só lhe
servem também para você ter uma
realização
é uma realização do momento de reflexão
de saber aonde você quer chegar aonde
você quer ir
e nessas realizações só você tem o
direito de falar até onde você pode ir e
só você tem o direito de parar o seu
sonho
ninguém mais tem o direito de parar o
seu sonho por você
somente você eu tenho feito muitas
palestras que me fizeram também a ter
mais tranquilidade está aqui na frente
de vocês hoje contando um pouquinho da
minha história e contando um pouquinho
do quanto cada passo e cada passo
pequeno é uma realização para sua vida e
é o momento que você tem que sentir
orgulho de você mesmo porque cada um tem
talento pra uma coisa cada um tem
talento pra uma profissão
basta saber como é que você vai levar
isso adiante
basta saber como é que você vai
estabelecer essa meta para sua
realização
e não adianta a gente dá passo grande os
pequenos passos são muito importantes
para grandes realizações e não permita
que ninguém absolutamente ninguém diga
que você não pode porque a única pessoa
que pode dizer pra você mesmo que você
pode ou não pode
são vocês então agradeço o carinho
agradeço o convite a minha experiência
de palestra um pouco menor do que as
pessoas que passaram por aqui porque pra
mim é um desafio novo não vou dizer que
eu tô acostumada
acostumada a falar sobre os meus
resultados a das entrevistas a talhe
lindamente de colã e representando o meu
país vestindo a minha casa eu vestir a
camisa do brasil dando as minhas
piruetas doidas enfrentando aquela trave
de 10 centímetros que pode parecer um
bicho de sete cabeças mas pra mim é o
que eu gosto porque eu gosto de desafio
então me desafiar ali é é uma realização
muito gostosa pra mim eu sei que tem
gente que chega perto ali daquela taxa
de 10 centímetros e fala assim
você que passa na sua cabeça pra você
subir aqui nesse aparelho e começar a
rodar e não ter medo mas é aí o meu
desafio da minha realização de gostar de
grandes desafios e nada mais é do que
uma fase nova pra mim topo nesses
desafios e sou assim tenho orgulho das
minhas realizações têm orgulho das
realizações da minha família porque meu
irmão
pendurou a medalha no no rio como o
vice-campeão olímpico mas ali estava
sendo tão medalhista quanto ele porque é
uma realização da família ea gente
acompanhou de perto todo o sofrimento do
meu irmão até ali então também faz parte
da minha realização como atleta como
pessoa ter tido a oportunidade de ter o
irmão que eu tenho do meu lado e ter a
família que eu tenho
então agradeço ao pessoal agradeço ao
carinho por tac hoje a oportunidade de
estar podendo passar um pouquinho pra
vocês as histórias e que o recado que eu
deixo pra todos vocês é tenham orgulho
de cada realização de vocês porque cada
realização de cada um de vocês é
importante sim pra si e para o
crescimento do nosso país então têm
orgulho de si e não permitam que ninguém
que ninguém destrua o sonho de cada um
de vocês vocês podem cada um tem
capacidade para alguma coisa cada um tem
capacidade para uma realização
basta a gente ter foco no nosso sonho ea
gente colocando pequenas metas
a gente tem um sonho muito grande a
gente tem que sonhar grande porque a
gente não sonha grande a gente não
realiza nas pequenas coisas então sonho
muito alto e coloque em pequenas metas
cada meta é como se você tivesse subido
um degrau de uma escada e sintam-se
orgulhosos a cada degrau que você
consegue subir porque você sabe que você
está um passo mais perto da realização
do seu sonho e da sua grande realização
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]